hi I'm Eric Nelson founder and CEO
augment and I am with hi I'm Jody Howe
I'm currying you I'm Skyler Joe and
we're students of happy brows math class
at Torrey Pines high school San Diego
California we're presenting a vision for
the use of learning tools to scale up
learning environments like the wolfram
summer camp or computer-based math we
worked on a piano skills visualizer
which is an example of a learning tool
that aggregates visualizes and feeds
back practice data into a student's
learning
okay welcome my name is Eric Nelson
founder of a company called augment we
live in Minneapolis and I work with Abby
Browns class in San Diego California
these are three of her students Corrine
Skyler and Jody each of them have worked
on a project that you're about to see
here there are also other students who
have worked on this project that are not
attending Ashutosh ah being a particular
example my job here introducing them and
their work is to convince you that
there's a golden age of mathematics
education i I know I'm kind of late to
the party here I Wolfram has given us a
tool mathematica obviously that enables
students to do a lot more in a lot
shorter time and with a lot less
experience than they would have to do
with the normal programming language and
we see a huge opportunity to make use of
this technology at all levels of
education not just college and possibly
not even in high school but that's the
focus right now so I connected with Abby
a few years ago now to work with their
students trained them in Mathematica
programming as a software development
discipline an engineering discipline and
actually develop real software which
then they go on and use in their
collegiate work and so it's all very
good for the students and we also have
things that we're developing using
Mathematica one of them right now then
I'm going to talk about and that they'll
demonstrate is actual learning tools
tools that we imagine will support the
assessment of understanding and of
course the the the big man on campus
for assessment of understanding is grant
Wiggins unfortunately deceased a couple
years ago his book understanding by
design has been prolific in terms of
educating educators on how to assess
understanding well as anybody who's used
normal tools particularly in math like
Khan Academy Khan Academy has an
excellent quizzing platform and it's
gamified and kids actually like to use
it
but we're not assessing understanding
really we're assessing procedural skills
and the question and I would say kind of
the holy grail of using technology in
education is can we actually from
practice data can we assess whether
someone understand something
sorry yeah okay anyway so we can we can
think about the implications the
opportunity that we have here is if we
have a transition between normal math
class which is lecture based and
typically it's exercise and procedural
skill focused preparing for various
tests and examinations if we were to
shift over to something like a year-long
well from summer camp I think that would
be in some ways we can imagine that as
an idealized way to learn math is just a
continuous knowledge making experience
using Mathematica as the tool to then
manipulate math and computational
thinking and also of course
computer-based math which is in some
ways that's that's a real in
instantiation in a schooling environment
as an obviously penetrated more than the
Estonian marketed but but we have a real
consequence that we have to face and
this this map of course just
demonstrates that we're behind in math
blah blah blah we all know that but it's
even worse than that I would say in many
respects all students are behind in math
because as Lockhart the guy who wrote
that essay about the travesty that we're
doing with the math education many
students really don't know how to
transfer the math concepts to
application and so they go through years
and years of study acquiring procedural
skills but they don't have the transfer
ability so it's even worse than this
math than this map would suggest now the
question of course is scale up how do we
scale up something like well from
summers summer camp or computer-based
math and as John McLuhan I think
standing at this spot exhibits over
there said yesterday assessment
assessment is a big problem how do we
assess these higher-order skill sets
cognitive skills and then how do we
communicate that we have assessed and we
we are making progress and that the
students are learning it's much harder
to compete with procedural skills
because those are easy to test and easy
to visualize various program progress
being made so
if we add this I'm actually ahead of
myself and this is also myself there so
if we can imagine a tool that would show
a student's capability and we can just
think about math for a moment we'll talk
about something else when these students
are demonstrating if we were to think
about capability as a topology a
topographical map or we can think about
it as a network of concepts and we can
think about heat maps we can think about
a concentration of competence
concentration of experience
concentration of projects and we would
link all this together into an
application which is queryable and as
you might imagine then if you have the
intention as either as a student or as a
teacher to learn a new thing to move
someone's mind into a new space you
would have a map of their current skills
and the current concepts that they
understand and you would simply be able
to plot a course and it's back to math
as many of these concepts can be related
semantically right they have they have
relationships in a network the semantic
web this is of course how we search for
things on Google there are tools that
already exist for certain subject matter
typing I would say is kind of like the
hello world of learning applications
because it's so easy to relate typing as
an exercise to typing as a performance
object it's the same exact thing and the
data is really easy to capture because
you're typing it in but there are other
things that are much harder this is
actually from this is an AI typing tutor
there are other things that are much
harder say for example piano piano is a
consist consists of both automatic
skills things like keyboarding and also
the higher order skills of composition
being able to hear music being able to
read music so they're all all different
kinds of skills being represented and
not simply the obvious automatic ones
ultimately we would say that assessment
of these higher order skills results
from and this is how we do it as humans
this is how the human brain works we
infer so a piano teacher of
deserves someone playing piano and from
their behaviors from their posture from
the sound and and usually you do a kind
of a gamete or what we might just call
an assessment set and and from that you
infer all of these other things but you
cannot scale that that is not something
that you can distribute over a course of
10,000 students and over a course of a
year because you don't have that many
experts who are able to assess so the
question is can we develop software to
do this this enables scalable training
we can imagine a particularly good piano
teacher would be able to infer and
interpret the results from a whole lot
of students and then they'll be able to
provide the personalized feedback which
is essential required for best growth
paths then for the augment side of
things we train programmers and they
themselves need to be able to infer from
the evidence what each other can do if
you have a team of people and anybody
who's done any project project work you
understand that if you're going to hand
something off to somebody else you need
to know that it can be done and then it
will be done properly well that's very
hard to do if you don't know what that
person can do and if you're relying on
certifications and other project
portfolio there's a lot of thing a lot
of things that can go wrong and so
really most teams operate entirely based
on their experience together and so they
get very close-knit and they're able to
interpret based on all that experience
but if you don't have that experience
what do you do so we're trying to answer
that question the tutor the the system
that we will be demonstrating are these
students will be is a system which
captures piano data which is in a MIDI
format and it a grits and feeds it back
to the to the learner and the key for
these sort of systems is the
signal-to-noise ratio you need to give
somebody the right information at the
right time both the teacher and the
student then from this our big question
is what are the edges of comprehension
how do we know that this
person knows XYZ concepts what is really
the subject matter that they understand
from this context there is a second tool
that has actually been around for quite
a while and it actually goes back
several decades in the form of military
and commercial aircraft certification
rating systems actually called
behaviorally anchored rating systems we
actually an advisor for my company
augment gary jed nak is an inventor of a
commercial form of what we would call
behaviorally ankle anchored self
assessment here's an example back to
this idea of observing behaviors if
you're looking at somebody in a wood
shop and they cannot hammer in in this
case it's six small nails in a piece of
birch without bending the nails without
denting the the workpiece well then you
would say they very likely could not
make a cabinet right so there there are
strong inference behavioral indicators
that we can pull from that context and
we can we can imagine this for all kinds
of skill domains so basa is another way
of very quickly getting to the heart of
the matter can this person do this do
they understand XYZ things there's a lot
of background to this I just left it
there so you can look at it later okay
I'm out of time so I'm going to move on
move over to our students here but the
big question is how can the computer be
better employed to grow express and
assess human understanding we think that
if we do a better job with assessment we
can scale up learning environments like
the wolfram summer camp and
computer-based math which as I see it
brings in this golden age of math
education and also for our purposes it
enables much better much faster
performance from high school level
students who can very quickly acquire
skills work together and and like Abby
was showing with her 3d prints they can
accomplish real useful things the proofs
of very various theories and experiments
like the the ramps
okay moving on so we have Kareem Jody
and Skylar they'll be talking about an
application that they developed to
assess and feedback handle skill so as a
part of augments program retraining we
each developed a common skill set using
resources that explain mathematica
concepts and principles of computational
thinking and after we have completed
this training template we work to create
a piano skills visualizer which provides
beginner piano players with feedback on
objective elements of their claim and we
used a few principles that allowed us to
work collaboratively in an efficient
manner so first we implemented what is
known as jigsaw teams to help us manage
our workload while in the development
phase we found ourselves more invested
in certain topics than others so we just
worked on parts that had the most
interest to us and we met up at the end
of each week to discuss our progress in
certain aspects of our project and also
we started designing our program in
English first in order to visualize the
general structure of the program that
we're creating before learning all the
specific functions that helped us to
implement our ideas and while coding we
also made sure to include comprehensive
documentation such as designers intent
and the pseudocode as you can see in
this example we have over here so that
anyone who opens our file are provided
context once they open a shirred file
and one thing another thing that we used
is something called a concept domain
which is a shared language that includes
a set of technical and musical language
also that we can standardize our
communication this is similar to how an
air traffic controller or a military
unit would use a domain-specific
language that allows them to be both
concise and clear
so more going into the piano projects
within this project specifically we
developed the project in a piecewise
manner with two main strategies we first
wrote simple functions that we later
made more complex and then the second is
we applied these functions first to
certain instances and then extended them
to more general applications so one way
to develop a large project like this is
to decompose it into parts which can be
combined later on musical sound although
artistic can be translated into a purely
computational problem by breaking it
down into objective elements like timing
note value and volume this nicely
corresponds with the MIDI file data
which also does note value and then
timestamps which are the starting time
and ending time of the note and then
next is key note velocity so this key no
velocity in piano players terms is how
hard you press a key however Mathematica
reads it as volume so in the beginning
we had a lot of difficulties generating
a lot of data that were similar to how
we were going to format our notebook so
we created a data generator so what it
would do is introduce errors into a
perfect MIDI piece that we had so as you
can see as an example as we have the
timing function from the top and then
from here you can see we had the
variation range the number of lessons
and implement improvement factor so this
was just also another way of us thinking
of long term analysis of thinking about
over time how a student would improve
and how this variation would become less
and less so if we go down to our data
generator this is bringing back the idea
of going from simple to complex so we
have the not only the timing now but we
also have note value and volume so we
have all this variation if we look at
the data generator at the top we have
the sliders which have the different
variation ranges and then the second on
the on the second the first sound note
file on the left is the perfect piece so
if we play it now there's a little bit
of a lag
and then our data generator would input
some errors into it so if you play the
right one now
so you can see on the bottom we also
introduced the idea of the lesson number
which is our attempt at long-term
analysis so this was lesson number is
how many times you would play the song
and then timing variation is just how
much varied it would be and the note
variation and volume variation follow
the same format if you would go down to
zero variation that means you play the
piece perfectly according to the exact
MIDI file and then the graph below is
also just a graph of the variations
between progressively in time so for the
analysis portion we took each of the
values along the progression of the song
showing what mistakes were made when and
where which served as strong and
intuitive visualization for the
computations will show more of the
visualization later but then we also had
to think of generating this instances to
general so we first had to hard-code
certain functions such as that mary had
a little lamb' piece so that was created
with Mathematica sound-up functions
where each note would be put into the
program and then while doing this we had
a better understanding of how the song
phone sound note functions worked and
how to create the computations done on
the file and then after doing the
functions for this piece we had to
generalize the code to be more
applicable to other songs as well so as
you can see here is the same data
generator however if we play the first
two seconds of this piece on the perfect
side and this was the perfect for if you
know the song entertainer and if we
played the right side now
[Music]
so as you can tell there's a big change
between the two so it just the center
general away with entertainer and then
we later after this we had to think
about real-world applicability so what
we did was we imported in an actual MIDI
file into this program and we thought
does our programs don't work
successfully it did and then yeah and
then now we have the visualization so
how we did this is we took the data
generated from the from our program that
looked at the mistakes that were made so
for the timing function if you can see
on the x-axis it's the time interval
between the songs so from zero to two
seconds that's the first quadrant from
two to four seconds it's the second
quadrant and then we have the cumulative
error on the side and it's just counting
how many times you make an error during
that certain time instants and then with
the with the timing error what the
timing graph does it also allows for
students and teachers to see during what
time interval do you see the most
mountainous takes whether it be from
properties of the song or from a
player's just disposition on the
difficulties of playing it and then on
the note graph you see on the x-axis we
have their practice MIDI notes and then
under y-axis we have the perfect MIDI
notes so what you would what this graph
would show is whether a student played a
B instead of an A and then what it would
do was would point it would it will
place a point on the XY axis and then
depending on how many mistakes you make
during that song it would go up by one
two or three or how many times you'll
make a mistake so in general if you had
a perfect piece with no makes mistakes
in the note it would just be a flat
plane okay so we'd like to see our
project expand in several directions in
the future so currently as you see it's
capable with the short term analysis but
we'd also like to extend it to long term
analysis because in the real world
teachers would probably want to see
trends in improvement along with the
current playing ability and we've
started implementing lesson number and
improvement factor variables to find
patterns of recurring mistakes we could
also analyze more complex technique
signatures so ad
these on top of the skill sets that we
already have could enhance the spectrum
of skill level analysis and provide
better feedback for a wider range of
songs and techniques so for example when
one kind of technique signature would be
syncopation and syncopation is when you
intentionally deviate from the normal
flow of rhythm so this could be another
factor that would be taken into account
when we analyze a student's recordings
our user interface is currently very
basic and the only way to import certain
files is to of course call import and
then specify the file location but this
might be a little bit cumbersome and
difficult for piano teachers and
students especially little kids so we'd
like to implement a more polish
interface that also generates our output
in a much cleaner fashion so to recap
this project was just one example of an
attempt to grow express and assess
student understanding in the piano
skills context so all of us are pianists
and we all had this was a useful
background to draw on when developing
this project but in the future projects
like this could be expanded to all kinds
of skill sets in order to capture
behavioral data which can then be
translated into inferential data
ultimately allowing us to predict and
improve future performance thank you for
listening
[Applause]